you may or may not know his name we were
among the first to report on him here on
special report but tonight we're
learning more about Bruce or one of the
people on the president's list whose
security clearances are now under review
as chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Harridge reports documents
show the Justice Department official may
be a key figure in the Russia scandal as
part of this review I'm evaluating
action with respect to the following
individuals James clapper James Comey
Michael Hayden Sally Yates Susan Rice
Andrew McCabe Peter struck Lisa Paige
and Bruce or or is the only official on
the White House list still working in
the US government a review by Fox News
affords Justice Department emails and
handwritten notes shows he is deeply
connected to the controversial Trump
dossier and during the presidential
election the scandal over alleged
government surveillance abuse it seems
like he's a key player Wars wife Nellie
were for fusion GPS the DNC in Clinton
campaign paid the firm for the Trump
dossier based on research by former
British spy Christopher Steele after the
FBI dropped Steele as a source for lying
in November 2016 the republican-led
House Intelligence Committee found that
still maintained contact using or as a
back-channel Bruce ORS wife worked for
the firm that the Clintons hired to put
together the dossier she's given it to
Bruce or he's given it to the FBI
it is never supposed to work that way in
the United States of America during
closed-door congressional testimony last
year the co-founder of fusion gps glenn
simpson famed no contact with or until
after the presidential election but ors
work emails conflict with simpson's
testimony showing contact months earlier
in December 2016 the notes also indicate
a meeting in Washington DC's Chinatown
with or writing quote Glenn gave me a
memory stick during recent congressional
testimony now fired FBI agent Peter
struck was pressed on or whose portfolio
did not include Russia the FBI received
documents in material from mr. or the
your documents shed more light on
Steele's activities before the
presidential election while steel shot
the dossier to multiple media outlets he
also asked or for help with a
Russian oligarch Oleg Deripaska after
rumors the US might impose sanctions and
when FBI director James Comey was fired
by President Trump or wrote this deal
was quote very concerned about commis
firing afraid they will be exposed today
the Justice Department declined to
comment or has a chance to tell his side
of the story on August 28th when a
closed-door interview was scheduled with
the House Oversight and Judiciary
Committees as part of their joint
investigation into the FBI and DOJ is
conduct during the presidential election
brett continued to follow a captain
thank you